[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight let's say you had deep
animus against the united states let's
say you hated the country and he wanted
to permanently knock the us from its
perch as the preeminent world power and
the degrade and humiliate america for
good
you might use afghanistan to do that and
if you wanted to here's what you might
do
first you would delay your withdrawal
from afghanistan for 19 years long after
there was any national security security
justification for being there you would
turn a war into a welfare program and
you would turn your military into an ngo
that would humiliate everyone involved
you would spend trillions of dollars to
do this but you'd be absolutely certain
to get nothing in return for that money
apart from dramatically increasing local
corruption and making opium poppies the
national crop as the occupying power you
would run afghanistan so badly with such
unbelievable stupidity and overbearing
arrogance that by the end much of the
population would yearn for the return of
brutal religious extremists
then when it was finally time to go you
would ignore the relevant details of the
withdrawal you wouldn't plan your exit
you would just hope for the best what
could go wrong in a country controlled
by the taliban
when crowds of desperate people showed
up as they inevitably would begging to
be evacuated you'd be certain to give
preference to the foreign nationals the
ones who might hate you and prefer
sharia law to democracy they would get
the first seats on the plane as for your
own citizens the people you exist to
protect we just wish them luck and leave
them behind
you wouldn't even bother to get all of
their names because really who cares
then having done all of that you go on
television back in your own country to
brag about what an amazing job you'd
done you'd call yourself a hero you'd
compare your evacuation of kabul to the
berlin airlift
and that way once you've done that the
rest of the world would know you're not
simply incompetent and weak but you're
also delusional you are a lunatic with
no self-respect
having learned all that your enemies
just might conclude that now is the
perfect time to take advantage of your
diminished condition
and today in kabul they did just that
a terror bombing at the airport killed
90 people and injured 150 more 13 of the
dead were american servicemen 12 marines
and a navy corpsman for the us military
it was the single deadliest day in
afghanistan in a decade it was a tragedy
and we saw it on television
in moments like this americans turn
instinctively to their president for
perspective and leadership it doesn't
matter if they voted for him they want
to be reassured by the man in charge
but joe biden did not reassure them he
didn't even appear for hours biden
remained hidden and silent finally the
white house announced that joe biden
would speak to the country at 5 pm this
afternoon
but even then he didn't show
joe biden was fully 25 minutes late to
the podium like he had better things to
do
and when he spoke it was hard to believe
this is the man in charge of our country
joe biden is fading before our eyes he
began by muttering something irrelevant
and weird about his late son beau whom
he described as the us attorney in
kosovo is if that position exists
and then biden pledged his voice weak
and halting speaking at a pace half
of what a normal person speaks at
that he was going to somehow hunt down
and punish the people who killed our
marines today
and all of a sudden this didn't sound a
lot like a withdrawal from afghanistan
at all
to those who carried out this attack
as well as anyone who wishes america
harm know this
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay
no you won't
unfortunately
the tragedy today was not a complete
surprise there was intelligence
suggesting it might happen just hours
before the attack the u.s embassy in
kabul's now operates from the airport
sent out the following alert quote
because of security threats outside the
gates of kabul airport we're advising
u.s citizens to avoid traveling to the
airport and to avoid airport gates at
this time u.s citizens who are at the
abbey gate the east gate or the north
gate now should leave immediately well
that turned out to be relevant
intelligence what did the pentagon do
with it well not much apparently they
were too busy tweeting about equity
this morning the sergeant major of the
army a man called michael grinston wrote
this quote women's equality day reminds
us we're smarter and more lethal when we
come together as an inclusive cohesive
team
okay so some large but as yet still
unknown number of american citizens are
trapped in afghanistan tonight all of
them facing potential death and here we
have the senior nco in the united states
army celebrating women's equity day
whatever that is send in the pregnant
fighter pilots
it's also humiliating serious people are
laughing at us which is probably the
point of doing it
on the other hand joe biden doesn't
really need the us military to protect
the kabul airport because the taliban
now have that covered
general kenneth mckenzie explained this
today at a press conference it was a
failure by
you know taliban operate with varying
degrees of confidence some of those guys
are very scrupulously good some of them
are not
some of those taliban guys were very
scrupulously good that was the official
word from the biden administration keep
in mind what you just heard from the
general he said after the taliban let a
suicide bomber through a checkpoint at
the airport that killed 13 americans but
still we're going to trust them
the bite administration trusts the
taliban enough tonight apparently to
share classified intelligence with them
again here's general mackenzie
the other thing we do is we share
versions of this information with the
taliban so that they can actually do
some searching out there for us and we
believe that some attacks have been
thwarted by them and then we also use
the taliban as a tool to protect us as
much as possible but we share a common
purpose to as as long as we've kept that
common purpose uh aligned they've been
they've been uh useful to work with
they've cut some of our security
committee some of our security concerns
down
so we now share a common purpose with
the taliban that's the head of the us
military telling us that so naturally
the taliban are now in charge of
protecting our citizens hey america
meech new bodyguards bad news is they're
the taliban
it's hard to believe any of this is
actually happening or that that clip
that we displayed is real but it is
happening and unfortunately that is a
real clip so what kind of information is
the bite administration now handing over
to the taliban well according to
politico quote u.s officials gave the
taliban a list of names of u.s citizens
green card holders and afghan allies to
grant entry into the outer perimeter of
the city's airport
wait what
we gave the taliban the names of u.s
citizens in afghanistan
we don't have special operators anymore
why are we doing that why would we give
it to the taliban that can't be right
well it is right it's true
the bite administration handed the
taliban a list of americans who were
still in afghanistan joe biden all but
confirmed that today apparently it makes
the taliban's job easier the question is
what is that job
that's one of many questions tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else